not only does the santis not get beat by
democrats has never lost an election uh
but he's completely obliterated the
Democrat Party in Florida it basically
does not exist the point is that he does
things differently the track record is
there I know you know it but now I want
to illustrate it as it relates to the
Border deal that is in the Senate right
now this is the Schumer Lankford border
deal so this is the Border deal that the
Republicans are signing on or
potentially signing on what's it going
to do well it's going to increase green
cards by 50,000 a year work permits for
adult children of hb1b holders immediate
work permits to every illegal alien
released from custody think about that
one taxpayer funded lawyers to certain
uac's and mentally incompetent aliens
5,000 migrants per day allowed into the
US restricts parole for those who enter
without authorization between ports of
Entry so yes the santis is absolutely
right the the Democrats blow but the
Republicans suck and what we have here
in Florida is a now a deeply deeply red
state that is functional and it's paying
off its debt and has no income tax and
is sane and we don't have homeless
problems and drug problems and all of
those things and we protect the First
Amendment and the Second Amendment and
maybe we can blueprint that throughout
the country and that's what could start
could could could start today in
Iowa